non ce n'est pas un ovni qui a atterré à
Azay
par l'entreprise de textile sportifs
skin up cette bulle gonflable abrite en
réalité plusieurs cours de tennis
flambant neuf équipée de capteurs vidéo
ici s’entraîne déjà une toute jeune star
de la raquette champion de France de la
catégorie des 11-12 ans Quentin Dodin
n'en est pas moins émerveillé par les
lieux c'était une joie quand tu joues
ici tu as le sourire de
c'est magnifique en fait les terrains
sont beaux
c'est je suis content ça coache Laurence
bois il y a installé sa nouvelle
Académie privée où elle propose des
cours de tennis aux adultes comme aux
enfants et pourquoi pas les former au
niveau c'est préparer à la victoire
préparer à la défaite s'est préparé au
tournoi c'est
savoir gérer ses émotions c'est savoir
se reprogrammer de match après match
parce qu'on gagne on perd donc c'est
tout le temps une petite remise en
question donc c'est dans tous notre rôle
à nous il va être dans cette préparation
là son école va bénéficier du soutien
d'un champion puisque Thierry dulan
dixième jour mondial en 1986 parraine
l’académie quand on a été joueur de haut
niveau et qu'on est passionné de tennis
on a envie de transmettre dans un super
lieu avec toutes les nouvelles
technologies avec des enseignants qui
sont qui ont fait leur preuve Laurence
bois qui qui est directrice de cette
académie elle a déjà formé plein de
jeunes championne et John champion le
site devrait s'agrandir puisque est
encore prévu la construction de 4 cours
en terre battus extérieur 4 pistes de
paddle et une zone multisport Amélie
detrivières membre de l'équipe de France
de paddle devrait y installer elle aussi
son Académie en 2023